um Tim the cast and crew that's here if
you want to come up please do please do
that I know they're right there come on
guys they're all over the place so it
might take a second
we roll deep for sure oh man um first of
all thank you to the Academy for
including us in such an amazing group of
filmmakers and setting this whole week
up for us on your team amazing the
fellow winners just hearing your words i
think if you haven't seen their films
just hearing them talk that's just a
testament to the filmmakers and the
people they are so it's an honor to be
included with them I'm up here
representing everyone by know one thing
that I've done I'm here because of the
grace of God and my amazing family my
brother Peter who's not here but I love
you mom dad thank you so much for
inspiring me supporting me teach me to
work hard holding things when I asked
you to like sweaters and water bottles
and everything I'm really excited to ask
you to hold this later and to the
amazing crew it started with an amazing
script by Dan kleiner screenwriter
our amazing producer John sage our
cinematographer John Chow our editor
ramin Tahiri our sound designer the
shang i'm going to start listing some
names off hoon Lee Wang our production
designer son signed on a week before I
film our first ad andris our amazing
cast my clan Walker Josh gone to a
lionel andres that i name you our first
ad on dress he kept me in line to our
cast you guys are the beating heart of
this film thank you for telling this
story thank you so so much and thank you
to everyone standing here I know I
there's so many people I wish I koda
nice Valentine our makeup artist she was
one person and to get all so many
amazing people and monitor stand here
and represent them and I have to thank
Chatham University thank you so much
to the faculty and administration and
and two are my fellow classmates thank
you so much for pushing me and
challenging means inspiring me you guys
make me a better better filmmaker you
make us a better filmmakers this tonight
is for all of us so thank you so much
guys